people in a St Louis suburb are outraged
by new evidence that an elementary
school has unacceptable levels of
radioactive contamination CBS News first
reported on the contamination in and
around fluorescent Missouri in 2015. a
recent round of testing highlights leaks
of radioactive material into nearby Cold
Water Creek dating back to the creation
of the first atomic bomb
an area has seen the cancer clusters and
other health problems for decades now
we're learning that the contamination
could be even more widespread Adriana
Diaz talked to some parents that are
demanding answers
when you guys start to see the level of
disrespect the department of energy had
for our community you're gonna be mad
I've been out as well
calling doctors having blood work done
any of those things that I can do right
now to test lead levels there is Fury in
Florissant Missouri after Jana
Elementary School tested positive for
Dangerous radioactive contaminants we
cannot allow our community to be
devastated by the poor choices of people
in the 40s the 50s the 60s and the 70s
the 80s the 90s and now we're here past
the 2000s that's PTA president Ashley
Bernard who's been fighting for
transparency for nearly a decade my
biggest fear is that our kids are going
to end up with illnesses later on in
life
and that it could have been prevented
how this is even possible dates back to
the 1940s and 50s when radioactive waste
was stored near what's now St Louis
airport contaminating the soil and
nearby Cold Water Creek which frequently
overflows
in 2012 the Army Corps of Engineers
which is responsible for cleanup of the
area began testing near the airport and
expanded to test along the creek Army
Corps communication to the school
district from earlier this year
acknowledged low-level radioactive
contamination but said it was within
acceptable parameters and while the
corps has tested 300 feet outside the
school the building itself is not within
its designated testing area the Army
Corps of Engineers denied us testing
said it wasn't reasonable and when
testing was done
they don't like the results lawyers
bringing a class action lawsuit hired
their own investigator who did test
inside the school building they found
unacceptable levels of radioactive lead
inside the kitchen gym and ventilation
systems at the playground lead levels
were 22 times higher than normal the
Army Corps of Engineers told us the
report is not consistent with our
accepted evaluation techniques and must
be thoroughly vetted the corps
acknowledges there is contamination
underground in a nearby wooded area but
says they found no contamination between
the creek and the playground has your
son talked about being worried for his
health sure
absolutely
um he understands the real ramifications
that come with radioactive nuclear
material this is the stuff his
superheroes fight against
there are already bipartisan calls in
Congress to investigate this now
students are attending school in person
today until Monday when they go virtual
through Thanksgiving after that the
students are going to be transferred to
different schools in the area until
further notice one parent we spoke to
off camera last night was in tears
because she doesn't want the school
split up
boy Adriana good point that mom made
this is the what his superheroes fight
against little kids understand that one
thank you Adriana thank you very much